back in Israel America's top Diplomat
touched down on Wednesday evening just
as another group of captives was
released by Hamas and 30 Palestinian
prisoners were being freed from Israeli
jails the Secretary of State came with a
clear message the US would like to see
the temporary ceasefire
extended and in a meeting with Israel's
president Isaac Herzog Anthony blinkin
called for the releas of captives to
continue in my meetings today with the
Prime Minister and Senior Israeli
officials I made clear that before
Israel resumes major military operations
it must put in place humanitarian
civilian protection plans that minimize
further casualties of innocent
Palestinians but his main focus was to
exert some influence over the next phase
of Israel's offensive in Gaza which is
expected to focus on the south of the
trip where the vast majority of gaza's
2.3 million people were forced to
flee the US and Israel believe hamas's
leadership is hunkered among them
Washington is wary of the enormous cost
this war has already had but stopping
Israel's war machine is not easy even
for the US
Administration and I told him that we
swore I swore to eliminate Hamas and
nothing will stop us we will continue
this war until we achieve the three
goals to release all the abductees to
eliminate Hamas completely and to ensure
that such a threat from Gaza will never
reoccur
again the Biden Administration is also
looking forward to Gaza after the war a
conversation that includes the
Palestinian Authority based in ramala
the US is seeking ways for the PA to
have a greater role in this trip while
Palestinians don't expect much when it
comes to the the US defending their
rights many are also skeptic about their
own leadership some say it's weak others
it's hands are tied but everyone would
agree that the real power resides in
that building which is the headquarters
of the Israeli military occupation in
the West
Bank it's from here that Israel keeps
its firm control on Palestinians issuing
orders and coordinating nightly raids
that have seen more than 3,300 people
detained since October
7th and president Mahmud Abbas gave the
Secretary of State a file with a list of
alleged war crimes committed by the
occupation forces in both the West Bank
and Gaza blinkin then returned to Tel
Aviv for more meetings a clear
indication that the old days of us
shuttle diplomacy in the region are back
H abdulhamid Al jazer
ramala make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer